[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes I'm Katie Bulls your host coming
up on the show
Vladimir Putin has threatened to use
nuclear weapons against the West if he
doesn't get what he wants in Ukraine but
would he really do it I'll speak to Paul
wood and Peter Hitchens
Houston isn't just having trouble abroad
he's being challenged domestically too
Lisa hasseldine will speak to a Russian
politician who openly says he wants
Putin to go
there's trust this week defended Bankers
bonuses and said that she's happy to be
unpopular if it gets Britain's economy
moving I'll speak to James assignment is
of a hard minute about well this is such
a good idea
violence between Hindus and Muslims has
flared up in the Midlands why I'll speak
to John Connolly
and finally Mike Liz truss's plan to pay
for Britain's gas bills cost far less
than first thought
I'll be joined by Kate Andrews who will
talk us through the economics
this episode is sponsored by canonical
genuity wealth management experience
wealth planners and investment managers
who offer unwavering support in
challenging times visit can do
wealth.com for more information
and while we have you here why not
subscribe to our YouTube channel too
click the red subscribe button at the
bottom of the video and tap the Bell
icon to make sure you never miss an
episode
an address to the Russian people on
Wednesday Vladimir Putin said he was
calling up Army reservists to serve in
Ukraine he also said that if pushed
Russia would use nuclear weapons against
the West
will the mobilization make a difference
and how seriously should we take those
threats
Paul wood writes this week's cover piece
about Putin's options he joins me now
alongside the journalist Peter Hitchens
Paul in the magazine this week you write
that Putin is cornered what has brought
us to this point
well he miscalculated they thought they
would take Ukraine in a matter of days
in fact that was their strategy a kind
of Russian version of shock and awe
where they put parachute paratroops on
the ground at the airport outside Kiev
they sent tanks towards the capital they
thought the Ukrainian government would
just crumple that people would panic and
a lot of the horrific stories we're
seeing about war crimes appear to have
been part of Russian strategy to terrify
people
um there's a thousand bodies turned up
north of Kiev another several hundred
south of Kiev this all seems to have
been strategy but what Putin did not
reckon on was that he had a hollow Army
and I spoke to um
various people who have kept very close
tabs on this operation and I was hearing
stories
um armored vehicles with bald tires
tanks running out of fuel the Twitter
account of this Russian peritry by
quoting the piece talks about going into
um basic training with Rusty rifles a
few rounds of ammunition for battle not
enough food no beds in the barracks so
um
this is why he's losing and of course
the ukrainians are fighting for their
own territory in their own land and this
is why too throwing another 300 000
troops uh into the battle is not really
going to help him that's why he's
cornered and that's why we're hearing
these increasingly desperate uh
statements from Russian officials
bringing nuclear weapons into the
equation
Peter Paul mentions
um some of the problems that Russian
soldiers have experienced some of that
also involves a you know faulty
equipment or not working as it should do
how much do you think there's this uh
Russian fail failings and how much is
actually Ukrainian success in terms of
tactics and employees
well uh here's the great Paradox of this
controversy for many years I've been
saying this claim that Russia is about
to invade the the old warsaw-packed
countries in the Baltic States was empty
because the Russian armed forces were
actually still the shambles and I got a
fair amount of derision from that and
now the people who are saying Oh look
The ukrainians have the Russians on the
run which they may do
won't accept that the the this point has
actually now improved that the Russian
the huge Russian threat which they
confected over a quarter of a century it
turns out to be largely empty and I
think people should pay more attention
to this development after the rest of it
I have never so much as put on a a Cadet
uniform at school or fire rifle so my
ability to comment on Military matters
is pretty limited I know other people
don't let these disadvantages get in
their way but I have very little idea of
what's actually going on militarily or
how it will work out I think people
should be careful I certainly think that
after I think the great mistake that
most people made up until February was
to assume that Putin was a rational
actor and then when he had invaded it it
was obvious to everybody whatever side
they were in this that he is not a
rational actor so we have to take
seriously this this talk of nuclear
weapons and to understand that we're
probably at greater risk
of nuclear war than at any time really
since the invention of of nuclear
weapons because this isn't like the
Cuban Missile Crisis where the huge
weapons are under the control of
centralized Powers something could
actually happen on a battlefield from
which other things could spread to who
knows what end I I think this is one of
the most frightening circumstances I've
experienced in my entire life
Paul do you agree with that Peddlers
trust the new prime minister to be
pretty dismissive of um Putin's nuclear
threats this week
um but do you think Peter has a point
here that that really you just do not
know what uh the Russian president is
going to do
Peter's absolutely right this is a
terrifying moment we have to hope that
Putin retains some rationality all the
people around him do because otherwise
the doctrine of mutual assured
destruction just doesn't work anymore in
the past when Putin has given some quite
measured statements about Russia's
nuclear Doctrine he said that they would
never initiate a nuclear attack they
would never
um do what the West did and so in the
view of many immorally for many years
and have a policy of First Strike not
just hitting first but hitting
with such a massive wave of nuclear
missiles that you destroy any offensive
capability in your enemy
um and he has said it would be the end
of civilization if there was a nuclear
war all very rational things now we have
him talking about nuclear blackmail by
NATO defining these people's republics
uh formerly in Ukraine still according
to international law in Ukraine as part
of Mother Russia and saying that all
necessary means will be used to defend
Mother Russia you have to hope as Liz
trust clearly does that he is bluffing
and that because he's losing the
conventional War he must turn to other
things
um principally the idea that he might
use a nuclear weapon not necessarily a
missile from Siberia to London but a
tactical Nuka which Russia has many now
we have to be a little bit cautious
American officials of anonymous
officials have told the New York Times
They don't see these tactical nuclear
weapons being moved into Ukraine yet but
it would be very easy for them to do
that and if you look at the Russian
media a lot of what we're seeing is just
crazy the people who you presume speak
for the Kremlin like the Editor in Chief
of Russia Today are saying either we win
the donbass back and solidify our
Victory on the ground or its nuclear war
with NATO there is no third option of
course we are right to be terrified
and Peter on that I mean there are some
who say oh don't worry about nuclear war
because where Putin to really try and do
it as generals those around him would
not let him go through with that
um but do you find that argument at all
convincing or reassuring
no because we know so little about the
internal politics of Russian government
and and military command and control I
don't know what what the procedure would
actually be if anybody wanted to stop
the president the other thing we have to
understand I think a lot of people
fantasize that if Putin fell he'd be
replaced by some sort of liberal
Democrat uh that is not very likely uh
the the likelihood is if he falls he'll
be replaced by somebody immeasurably
worse and I I think the the pressure
which he has been under from extreme
Russian nationalists is something we
haven't really
fully understood and they are the people
who would benefit most from his
departure so the idea that it would be
it's a good idea to to destroy his
forces and bring him down seems to me to
be enormously and dangerously
short-sighted again who who wants a
major nuclear power run by Maniacs
unknown to us uh possibly crazier than
anybody outside North Korea and even
more crazy it's it's very strange the
the sort of dream time way in which many
Western commentators and politicians
approach this as if it isn't really
happening on this planet but it's a sort
of video game in which they they can
score triumphs and make Rising speeches
this is some actual war on Continental
Europe which could within weeks uh go
nuclear and I just don't see any serious
attempt by anybody to understand the the
the and I'm using the word here in its
proper sense the enormity of this was to
recognize the very very serious need to
find some way of bringing an end to the
conflict which will which will be
permanent and effective that's what we
should have been doing from the start it
was always a fantastically dangerous War
now it's become even more so
now in terms I want to get to that point
which is uh how can this all play out
how could it end but just before we do
Paul do you agree with that in a sense
of
um after Putin actually what comes after
putting could be worse
either an extreme nationalist or
somebody like Nikolai patachev who runs
the Russian National Security Council
but like Putin used to run the internal
security service the FSB and his equally
as dark and as Sinister a character as
Vladimir Putin
um you know we're playing uh roulette
here aren't we with um with the phase of
the world as Peter says enormity is the
right word so question is what do we do
about that one very logical response is
to press the ukrainians
um to go to peace talks and to give up
some of their territory I speak
regularly to Ukrainian officials they
are not going to do that they want not
only to retake these people's republics
and let's not forget that the Russians
are claiming some 20 of Ukrainian
territory now if you include Crimea but
the ukrainians want to go on to Crimea
itself and I think Peter's been to
Crimea several times uh I have as well I
think most people in Crimea want to be
in Russia they're Russian speakers it
only was handed to
um Ukraine by Khrushchev in the 1950s
but the ukrainians want it back and they
now feel they have the upper hand of
course they have the upper hand because
of weapons supplied
by the United States principally but
also Britain and others and the U.S has
been trying to calibrate this very
carefully there is a debate in the US
now about whether to give the Ukrainian
some quite powerful long-range missiles
the ukrainians say they need these
because
Putin losing with his infantry is now
hitting Ukrainian infrastructure with
his own long-range missiles conventional
missiles taking out things like power
stations ukrainians say this has got to
stop it is in itself a war crime but the
concern is that they would then start
dropping long-range missiles supplied by
the US on Russia itself an attack on
Mother Russia which Putin was saying on
Wednesday would be treated with the
utmost seriousness
um part of the problem here is that we
always treat every crisis like Munich if
we don't stand up to this dictator
Saddam uh you know the Korean leader
then we will see more and more territory
gobbled up well for once you have a
crisis that does in fact look like
Munich I think if Putin had not been
stopped by the ukrainians he would have
looked at the Baltic states he might
have looked elsewhere
but now we are at
a very very fine point of judgment and I
don't know how people like Liz truss or
President Biden are going to solve this
but they have to calibrate their
response not to put any more pressure on
Vladimir Putin so that he does do
something crazy because we don't know
the State of Mind of this man
they're on that point Liz trust did say
this is foreign secretary she is now
prime minister but when she was in the
foreign office she also argued that the
ukrainians really should be able to push
uh Russia from Crimea and so obviously
pre the February Invasion
um Peter do you think then if if the
Western leaders are currently obviously
supporting Ukraine and suggesting that
Ukraine can decide uh whether to go into
peace talks and they are not
it's really hard to see how this ends
without one side claiming Victory isn't
it oh come on if the United States
wanted to end this war it would end
tomorrow uh Ukraine's supposed uh
victories and all the rest we do not
know and probably will not find out for
years exactly how great the direct
Western involvement in Ukrainian
military performance has been with the
United States decided he wanted to end
this war It could only the question is
what it should how it should end it
isn't fundamentally about territory in
my view it's always been about the
pivotal position of Ukraine and if if
Ukraine joins the Western military
Alliance it transforms European and to
some extent global politics and makes
Russia a much diminished parent that's
that's the the real origin of this my
own view is you could end this quite
easily without with that an actual
return of Crimea to Ukraine provided
Ukraine was prepared to accept a federal
structure in which its russian-speaking
population were treated rather better
than they have been I think that would
be the obvious way out of it which
wouldn't involve any surrender of
territory and therefore surrender a
principle which ought to be seriously
pursued uh the Ukraine could be it could
be delighted by the return of Crimea
Russia would then go to Ukraine which is
unlikely to pursue these fantasies of
being a member of a western military
Alliance and we might then go back to
something approaching stability but I'm
just not sure whether the people in
charge of policy in Washington actually
want that and this is what scares me on
the issue of Munich
in 1965 Lyndon Johnson thought seriously
about pulling American Support away from
the South Vietnamese government and
getting out of Vietnam and he confided
to his friends the reason he didn't do
it was he was afraid of being called a
Neville Chamberlain and he was afraid of
of being told as he'd committed to
Munich this ridiculous is Trope the word
this ridiculous idea that all foreign
crises are a repeat of September 1938 is
so ridiculous and so wrong and the whole
the whole use of the word appeasement
appeasement simply means a bit of
diplomacy I don't like Churchill abused
Starlet and Roosevelt abuse darling Yota
the the British government under strong
American pressure appease the Irish
Republican Army in Belfast in 1998
Israel is under constant pressure to
appease the Arab world by land for peace
and these things are not called
appeasement because everybody approves
of them sometimes you have to reach
agreements because Powers exist and
countries exist and unless you want to
have a situation a permanent war and
horror you have to settle for that
thank you Peter thank you Paul
Peter isn't just struggling abroad he's
having trouble at home too Lisa
hassadine the spectator's Assistant
online editor writes in this week's
magazine about the politicians who are
speaking out against the Russian leader
earlier she spoke to Dmitry beltrakov in
Russian
thank you very much Katie
today I am joined by Dimitri balthrakov
one of the local councilors in a
district of Saint Petersburg who voted
to send a letter to the state demo of
Russia calling on them to impeach Putin
and charge him with treason
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah
again this is
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
to that
explosions because I took the um
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
this trust this week said that she's
fine being unpopular if that's what it
takes to grow Britain's economy
it comes with the government defended
alleged plans to remove a cap on Bankers
bonuses as well as plans to cut stamp
Duty Elite to the papers what does
truss's plan for their economy mean for
her Premiership
I'm joined Now by our political editor
James Forsyth an assistant editor Isabel
Hardman
Isabelle James thank you for joining the
week in 60 minutes now politics is back
this week James how has Liz truss kicked
things off so Liz Ross has gone to the
UN General Assembly in New York where
she's made a speech emphasizing lots of
the themes that she that that she talked
about when she was foreign secretary
about reducing dependence on
orthographic regimes how the Free World
needs to be stronger economically so
that it can stand up to Russia and China
she's also talked about domestic
politics while she's there and in some
ways these are the first kind of
interviews she's given since becoming PM
obviously because she was silent during
the period of national mourning and she
said look that she's a prime minister
who's prepared to do unpopular things to
get economic growth going she has uh you
know robustly defended her plan to
remove the cap on Bankers bonuses uh I
think it's become quite clear from her
comments as well but they are looking at
some action on stamp Duty uh in the
fiscal event on Friday and I think she
is trying to say
that she is a kind of growth prime
minister
um one former cabinet minister said you
know David Cameron used to say that you
could sum up his priorities in three
letters NHS Liz trust is trying to say
that you can sum up her her priorities
in three lessons GDP
is about on that trip
we had to rule out the prospect of a UK
US trade deal anytime soon does that
come as much as a surprise
not really I mean in terms of the the
actual policy I think no one was really
expecting it uh to be uh drawn up and
signed off anytime uh soon uh not least
because Joe Biden has made clear that um
that he's not going to contemplate
something like that
um when he's so worried about the UK
government's Direction Over the Northern
Ireland protocol and but also
domestically it doesn't really work for
the US to be um signing trade deals with
anyone at the moment
I think what was a surprise was Liz
truss who has been in the past and
you've written about this Katie uh quite
the most gung-ho I think um of uh senior
conservatives about the prospects for
the US UK trade deal to the extent that
she irritated
um uh colleagues in Downing Street when
she was International Trade secretary
um I I think it's surprising that she's
admitted that
and James when it comes to I suppose the
the formation of Liz truss's government
a lot of this was put on pause because
of the Queen's passing and but we have
had the final Junior ministeria
appointments made this week and there
are quite a few unhappy Tori MPS
um not such a rare sighting in recent
years uh complaining it's all about
loyalty and they've been left on the
sidelines is she storing up trouble for
the months to come
supporters appointed to the government
you know Jacob young Claire coutinho but
when you look through the whole
government ranks you know it is clearly
very heavily uh based on those people
who backlits trust either in the
Parliamentary rounds or once it got to
to the membership stage and I think that
there is a the the the view in uh in
kind of in trusses Downing Street is
look we've only got two years and they
think they've got to do a lot of stuff
to get to get the economy moving to
build a case for re-election and so they
have gone for a government where they
think that you won't have decisions held
up by ministers saying well I'm not sure
about this or I'm not sure about that I
mean they want to go hell for Lever and
they're trying to pick a a a a
government that can help them do that I
also think they want quite a lot of
Freeman maneuver uh and I mean you see
that actually in this roster's decision
to say that she's not expecting a trade
deal with the us anytime soon I mean
that is designed to say look don't don't
think that on the Northern Ireland
protocol you can say to me oh if you do
this or do that you're going to harm the
chance of a trade deal so I think she is
trying to give herself maximum room for
maneuver and a whole series of these
issues I mean the question comes you
know
how you if you don't build out at this
point I don't think it's going to be a
problem in any way early doors because I
also think that you know Tori MPS know
but Aaron said well action only two ways
two years away I think where it gets
difficult is if a government hits a
sticky patch you haven't done much to to
to to reach out and that is the risk
she's running but I think as you can see
in our whole approach to government she
is going for a high risk High reward
approach
um now Isabel you've interviewed the
shadow Health secretary was streeting in
the magazine this week and we're also as
part of uh Liz truss's government's push
to say they are doing something they're
getting on the job to raise coffee's
been announcing some of her plans and
the new health secretary which includes
the idea everyone should be get be able
to get an appointment within two weeks
how does she plan to do that
yes so you mentioned the uh James
mentioned um David Cameron summing up
his priorities as NHS and I think NHS
are probably the letters
um that are Liz truss's greatest
problems we've got more letters being
added by Therese coffee she wants to
solve the
ABCDs which is uh catchy and uh as part
of that that's the uh the GP appointment
uh that you mentioned and there are
various ways in which she is planning to
um to achieve this uh partly through
um a a cloud-based phone system
um which will reduce the need for um you
know anyone who's tried to get a GP
appointment on the day knows what it's
like phoning up at 8am
um being stuck waiting or hearing that
busy tone while also you know it's not a
particularly convenient time of day for
a lot of people who are trying to get
out the door to work or who are on a
train already and don't particularly
want to discuss uh with the um the
receptionist why they need an
appointment on the day and so on and so
that should that's one of the ways in
which um uh she's hoping uh that it will
make it slightly more um user-friendly I
think
um uh and that's something that we're
streeting also highlighted in um mind's
view with him that uh he doesn't want to
be somebody who represents the producer
interests in the Health Service and
indeed he talks a lot about his own
experience
um as someone who's been treated in the
past couple of years for kidney cancer
of seeing a system that is set up with
the system in mind not the patient in
mind and that you know he spent quite a
long time having to Trail around the
hospital to find a form that was going
to be put on some blood tests that he
was having when it should really have
been the the hospital that was able to
produce that form
um for him rather than him getting stuck
up in this sort of web of bureaucracy
and so I think we're going to see a lot
of uh chat about how to make the Health
Service work for patients
um but of course you know however you
streamline things um and however quickly
somebody gets an appointment in primary
care if they're not then able to move on
to an acute setting if they need it
including elective treat elective
surgery and so on then um then that's
not really going to address uh the the
growing public dissatisfaction with the
NHS
um which you know history suggests uh
the public don't tend to lay at the door
of nurses and doctors they blame the
politicians
now the biggest event of the week is on
Friday and we're recording today's
episode on Thursday the day it goes out
but James when we're looking ahead to
that mini budget which might really not
be so many after all we know that Liz
truss and quasiquartang want to show
they are going for growth that is the
core strategy of this government when it
comes to meeting spending commitments
but is there a chance that when they
announce these various measures and you
mentioned some of them so the idea of
flow to there could be a stamp Duty cup
and there's also talking of course um
scrapping the care from Bankers bonuses
and that there could be some Market
reaction there's already warnings that
this is unsustainable so what are the
potential problems so I think one risk
is that that people say look there's no
obr forecasts um you've already got the
ifs warning that debt is on an
unsustainable footing and that you know
the UK you end up with with Sterling
going down and guilt yields are going up
that that is a that is a danger I think
the other Danger series politically you
know there are there are even some
ministers worry that you know when your
first impression is you know here we go
in times of you know we're gonna uh
cancel an increase in the tax on on
large corporations profits we're going
to uh remove the cap and bankers bonuses
you know is that is that what you want
your introduction to the public to be
now I think there's got some quality
quarterings for you is that the most
important thing is for the Tories to
reassert their low tax pro-growth
credentials and but I think one of the
crucial things to understand is they
they want their dividing line of Labor
not to be the deficit as it was for
David Cameron and George Osborne but
they want it to be tax cuts now labor
will say tax cuts for whom you know who
is going to benefit from these tax cuts
but I think this draw some quality want
to have that argument and I mean that is
and so I think how that plays out is
going to be one of the key things of uh
the next few weeks I mean I mean this is
also a test of something that you've
written about Casey which is
Liz Ross is very convinced that these
red wall voters who turned for Tories
for the first time in 2019 you know they
want distinctively conservative policies
and so she thinks they are they are they
are gonna like this budget I think the
question becomes uh this is the test of
that you know is that the right analysis
because labor are going to go after it
for the fact that you know there isn't a
new windfall tax on the energy companies
who are making such huge profits at the
moment because of what's happened to
prices in the wake of pussy's invasion
of Ukraine uh but that they're removing
the capital Bankers bonuses at a time
when when lots of other workers are
facing real times pay cuts so you're
going to see a kind of classic left
right ding dong after this statement on
Friday
and just finally Isabel um you mentioned
those comments from Liz truss on that
trip where she was saying you know she's
prepared to be unpopular is that what it
takes to grow the economy
it's obviously quite easy to say you're
prepared to be unpopular um but do you
think history shows that Prime Ministers
tend to cope with it well when it
actually happens
no I mean no no politician uh is
engineered to enjoy being unpopular uh
you know their whole sort of life cycle
involves them trying to get people to
like them so it's it's very difficult
for them to really personally relish uh
being unpopular and the person she
models herself on Margaret Thatcher
um would get very uh upset and shaken
um when the public were were turning
against her
um and when she uh seemed when she
decisions she was making or ideas that
she had
um uh threatened her popularity indeed
she there were some things that she sort
of you know Drew back from because she
was worried about the uh response of the
electorate and I think there's a
difference if you look back at that
there's a difference
um between people getting angry with her
who wouldn't have agreed with her anyway
um you know the left um and I think at
the moment we're in a place where both
Liz truss and kissed armor are quite
happy with the dividing lines between
the two of them particularly on energy
policy you know she's completely
unashamed about not going for a windfall
tax and she's very happy to explain why
she's not going for a windfall tax okay
starmer is very happy that she's not
gone for a winful tax and he can talk
about how this is you know how being on
the side of big business and so on and
so forth um
so there's that and then there's
actually the the people who she wants to
back her
um uh liking her or not the electorate
and uh you know you might have a few
months
um six months where things are very
bumpy in the polls but there comes a
point where any prime minister and of
course the the Party Machine around them
starts to get very nervous uh if voters
are still crossed with them and an
election is looting and this is the the
problem uh with the time frame in which
Liz trusses is operating that she
doesn't actually have that much time in
which to be unpopular it's not like the
start of the you know the Coalition
where we have the fixed terms
parliaments act and they'd only just
come in after a general election and so
there were you know five years for them
to be unpopular and then to move on
she's really got 18 months and that's um
that's not easy at all
thank you Isabel thank you James
violence has broken out between Hindus
and Muslims in cities like Leicester and
Birmingham John Connolly The Spectators
news editor says in a piece this week
that the trouble started in August when
India defeated Pakistan and the cricket
to explain more he joins the show now
John thanks for joining spectator TV
this week can you start by explaining
when the violence between Muslims and
Hindus broke out
yeah of course and thank you for having
me on um so it all kind of kicked off
properly at the end of August on the
28th of August when a cricket match took
place uh not in England but in Dubai
between India and Pakistan India won the
match and basically shortly afterwards
in Leicester on Melton Road a load of
young Hindu men came out on the streets
a lot of them had uh Indian Flags
apparently this is quite a common thing
in Leicester whoever wins the India
cricket India Pakistan cricket match the
The Winning Side tends to come out and
celebrate and sort of blocks off the
road with cars and that kind of thing
um but what happened this time is it
kind of turned a bit nasty afterwards a
fight broke out
um someone has been arrested on
suspicion of assaulting an emergency
worker
and that was kind of the trigger point
even if even if the tensions didn't come
out of nowhere
um and sort of in the days after that in
the in the sort of week after in early
September there were a couple more
incidents
um that the police are currently
investigating
um basically nothing has been completely
confirmed at this stage but the kind of
the rumors are not spreading online
certainly seems to be case so that we
can't verify that is that kind of uh
individuals of have been sort of
targeted by people of the opposite faith
in gangs of young men there are also
videos coming around of sort of gangs of
people running around the sort of the
streets and Terraces of Leicester and
all this kind of bubbled away and and
was looking quite nasty
um but then we kind of saw a break just
just before the queen dad actually on
the 8th of September
um around then and it all seemed to die
down a bit at that point and we had a
sort of just over a week or so where
things had calmed down it seemed like
Leicester police had it all under
control until that is last Sunday
um when it when it all kicked off again
essentially and a Hindu protest started
um that seemed to be followed by Muslims
coming out on the street as well and
basically there's a there's a huge
standoff in the streets of Leicester
with bottles thrown the police really
struggling to control the situation and
the whole thing looking looking quite
dire
now John the local MP Claudia Webb has
blamed right-wing elements um is there
any evidence uh to support the idea that
this is in stoking some of the conflict
no and not that I've Seen It All To be
honest I mean it seems to me that the
problem is sort of videos and stories
getting passed around within specific
communities so for example in the Hindu
Community they'll be saying oh
um a Hindu man was targeted by Muslims
and vice versa on the other side and
this is kind of what's stoking up
tensions
um the flip side of this as well is that
clearly some violent incidents are
taking place so it's kind of this sort
of quite a toxic mix of violence
actually taking place then there's all
rumors of other violence taking place
and all of this is escalating where
people are saying well lots of young men
are saying definitely like we can't just
let this be we have to go out and get
revenge or escalate or go protect our
people on the streets and that's kind of
leading to more violence so a positive
seems to be that Leicester police kind
of seem to have gotten back control of
the situation since Sunday there's been
no reported incidents
um but the obvious risk is that this
flares up again because even the
smallest incident can can turn into into
violence and disorder essentially and
you mentioned some things that police
are doing as a much finding that the
British government can do in terms of
stepping in here
I'm not sure to burn as I think a heavy
police presence is is probably the best
thing
um the reality is is that the community
tensions are pretty dire at the moment
and you know these are problems that
India has seen for example it's not the
kind of thing that's easy easy to sort
out so I think the most they can do is
is keep the police on the streets I mean
there was talk that some of the reason
there might have been more difficulties
on Sunday was that lots of Leicester
police were down in London for the
Queen's funeral
um I think anything that reduces police
numbers in the areas is a bad idea at
the moment and as well um police forces
in other Midlands area should do the
same because I think we've seen as well
that it's it's possibly not going to be
just contained in Leicester at the
moment and John last question ultimately
you've been speaking to Residents in
Leicester what is the mood like there is
there a sense of panic across the area
or does it feel as though this is in
very specific areas
and there's a lot of unease I think um a
lot of these fans is actually spread
over quite a couple of areas in eastern
North sort of North Leicester
um I think there's a lot of people are
feeling a lot of fear at the moment I
think that especially applies to the
older generation and people who are more
like to wear religious dress that
they're going to be targeted by someone
of the other Faith there's also a lot of
anger about these young men who are who
are causing a huge amount of trouble and
and a lot of anger towards that from
both people inside both communities
um yeah it's not a great situation at
the moment to be honest um we can only
hope that it kind of doesn't kick off
again
thank you John thanks for joining
spectator TV today
and finally finally while the government
has been reluctant to put a price on Liz
truss's promise to freeze gas prices
which some have predicted cost as much
as 150 billion she could have some
elements moving in her favor when the
government finally gets around to doing
the sums
Kate Andrews joins me now to talk
through why some believe this could be
cheaper than first estimated
Kate in this week's magazine Julian
Jessup writes that Liz truss's energy
policy could be one of the most
expensive in history or not that at all
can you explain why
so Julian Jessup is an independent
Economist but as we learned in the
magazine a few weeks ago he's also been
one of the three economists he was
feeding in to the Liz trust campaign
advising her economic policy and I think
there's a sense uh that there's still a
lot of influence there his work is
certainly influential when it comes to
the trust government's economic thinking
and his argument in the magazine this
week is an optimistic one he's saying
look if you look at the way that gas
prices are going especially in recent
weeks there's been a big fall in the
wholesale price of gas this would
suggest that when it comes time to
actually tally up that bill for the
energy price guarantee which will see
the average household in the UK roughly
have a cap around 2 500 pounds per year
for their energy bill it may not
actually cost the government as much as
people are currently speculating because
we've had such a plummet in gas prices
now of course the difficulty here it's
difficult for the government it's
difficult for us is any kind of
prediction because we simply don't know
what's going to happen to gas prices
there are reasons to be optimistic as he
points to in the magazine but we don't
know how this winter is going to pan out
with governments across Europe pledging
to essentially cap Energy prices use
price controls also pledging that there
aren't going to be blackouts there is
still going to be a real Rush on gas and
electricity this winter so it's
difficult to say exactly what's going to
happen to prices the argument that the
government's roughly use so far is that
we can't really put costs on this
because we just simply don't know how
much it's going to cost overall but of
course they could be doing scenarios we
could have a scenario if gas prices were
to have we could have a scenario if gas
prices were to double
speculation conservative speculation
before we actually knew what the policy
was for households and businesses which
has turned out to be a lot more generous
than people thought it was going to be
was that this scheme could be anywhere
between 150 and 200 billion pounds over
two years Julian jessup's argument in
the magazine is could be well lower but
even if it were half that we'd still be
looking at something like the cost of
the entire furlough scheme so in terms
of Peace time we're still talking about
one of the biggest hands-out handout and
subsidies possibly in in the British
government's history
and Kate why is the wholesale price of
gas folding do we do we know that
so countries like Germany have done a
very good job much better than we
thought in actually getting their
reserves up Germany's reserves for
gaster now around 90 percent and there
was real concern especially when Russia
started turning off the Taps earlier on
in this conflict as after Russia invaded
Ukraine that Europe was really going to
struggle to get supplies but it does
seem to be that things are slightly
evening out but what we don't know since
governments have brought in very
generous policies to essentially cap
prices for consumers and now in the UK
for businesses for at least six months
as well is whether or not that anyone's
going to change their energy habits I
think this is actually really important
point because everyone's talking about
sort of how households now have this cap
of 2500 pounds well the cap is actually
on the unit price of energy which is
going to be less than half the wholesale
price so there's a huge subsidy going on
the government the taxpayer picking up
so much of that bill but if you use more
energy you this winter your bill is
going to be higher obviously than
somebody who doesn't because it the cap
is on that unit price not on the
official figure that you're going to pay
so I think the big question is have
these policies been designed in a way
that will still encourage us to safely
and responsibly tone down what we use
this winter to use slightly less to turn
off more lights to maybe have the
heating on for uh an hour less a day if
we're in a household that would allow
for us to safely do that if people
continue to use the same amount of
energy as it did last year or indeed if
they use more energy because of these
subsidies then we could be in for a real
headache when it comes to supply I mean
supplies are still much more limited
than they were before this war started
but we have been seeing countries that
we were so worried about like Germany
making up for that Supply elsewhere
which is giving us a bit more optimism
that actually there will be enough
Supply to get through the winter and yet
okay the Prime Minister Liz truss has
made it pretty clear she is not going to
be suggesting to the public they reduce
how much energy they use or ration in
any way so do you think people might
personally make that choice based on the
fact that bills will still be more
expensive this year than last year
well the government's line here is
interesting because on the one hand Liz
truss has said there will be no energy
rationing this winter now I take some
issue with this just on a technical
point I mean all energy is rationed the
way that we currently use energy you
know we use the price mechanism to
ration what she really means is there'll
be no mandated rationing that's coming
from the state the state is not going to
tell you that you can only use a certain
amount of Supply
um is she making herself a hostage to
Fortune here possibly because if
supplies dwindle and you know we're
talking about Global Supply chains here
something that a domestic government
doesn't necessarily have a lot of power
over
um you know she could find herself in a
very difficult position where she might
have to u-turn on that especially
because she's gone for Price controls
and decided to um let's say fudge the
extent to which people really understand
um the uh the market signals about how
much Supply we have that being said
there does seem to be suggestion that
there's going to be a public campaign
about how one can reduce their energy
bills this winter so there is
acknowledgment from the government that
again those who are in a safe position
to do so who won't be harming themselves
putting their health at risk or their
family's health at risk who can wean
some of their energy usage you can pull
that back a little bit it does seem like
there could be some public messaging um
although there's also nervousness in the
trust government I hear that that could
be two Nanny state so I think there's a
bit of an internal battle going on as to
what extent they want to encourage the
public to change their behavior this
winter and for those who perhaps either
don't want that campaign I don't want to
wait for it I would highly recommend
reading Lionel shriver's column from a
few months ago where she gave her own
tips on reducing energy bills something
she's been doing for some time and she
also gave an interview on spectator TV
and and just finally Kate
um when Liz trust announced there's lots
of people said oh this is a much bigger
intervention than we expected and some
sort of went against her no handouts
comments during the leadership campaign
but how does it Stack Up When We compare
it to what other countries across Europe
are doing
so she has very much followed with some
other European countries have done I
mean France decided long before the UK
did that they were essentially going to
cap costs for their consumers it
certainly does go against her no
handouts comments at the start of the
campaign but to be fair she seemed to
backtrack from those very quickly even
during the campaign I think there is
wide acknowledgment regardless of your
economic beliefs your ideological
beliefs that in order to get through
this winter there was going to have to
be support especially for the most
vulnerable households the question has
always been not whether or not you give
out that support but exactly how you go
about doing it I think what's still to
me most surprising about the policy that
trust came up with is just how not free
market it is I mean price controls are
just sort of bread and butter socialist
policy the fact that she's removed
market indicators the fact that frankly
this is going to be a huge chop up for
the wealthiest households and those who
have the biggest households this was not
targeted support this was massive
Universal support which she has pledged
for households for two years for
businesses at six months and then it
gets a little gray as to who will be
receiving the support and who won't
we're getting huge tax announcements
we're getting huge supply cyber Supply
cyber forms from the trust government
and they wanted a policy which
essentially protected them to give them
the space to talk about tax to talk
about her other public policy proposals
without being accused every day of why
aren't you caring about energy bills why
aren't you doing more for vulnerable
households she certainly achieved that
because I think it's near impossible for
labor or any other party to say that she
hasn't gone far enough she's gone very
very far the question to come back
around to Julian jessup's argument is
will this prove to be a hundred fifty
two hundred billion pound package for
which she has not even attempted to cost
those figures all of which will be
thrown onto the debt or is it possible
that we're going to get lucky Global
Supply chains are going to work in our
favor the gas price will continue to
fall and this will be a very expensive
policy but perhaps not as expensive as
speculation currently is suggesting
thank you Kate thanks for joining us
today
that's it for this week
once again thanks to Canada wealth
management for sponsoring the week in 60
minutes they will provide you with the
expertise you need to help build your
wealth with confidence visit can do
wealth.com for more information
and don't forget to subscribe to the
spectator's YouTube channel just click
the Subscribe button at the bottom of
this video and tap the Bell icon so you
never miss an episode
thanks again for watching and do join us
again next week
[Music]